hi I'm Eric Boston one mr. to come out
of Avengers infinity war surrounded the
Infinity Gauntlet when was it created
and how does it connect to the MCU
backstory where did it really come from
who wanted it before Thanos
why is gauntlet now a new theory has
emerged that actually provides a really
interesting explanation for this
timeline of events basically how Thor
Ragnarok actually contained a hole
deeper layer of meaning that we
overlooked so let's dive into it okay
according to this reddit theory Odin
all-father to Thor Loki originally
sought the Infinity stones and the
Infinity Gauntlet embarking on this
quest
long before Thanos fit Odin's father Bor
took the reality stone from the Dark
Elves a backstory that we learned about
in Thor the dark world so the idea is
that board taught his son Odin all about
the Infinity stones and that when Odin
rose to the throne he began scouring the
universe for them at his side was his
firstborn hella we learned in Thor
Ragnarok that before Thor was even born
hello was Odin's weapon in the conquest
that built Asgard's empire one by one
the realms became ours but then simply
because my ambition outgrew his he
banished me this conquest could have
actually been motivated by Odin and
Hellas search for the Infinity stones we
know that Odin possessed the space stone
this would have allowed him to transport
his armies from place to place and
conquer them pretty easily and he used
this might to rule over a vast empire
that encompassed the nine realms one of
these realms is of course Nitta Valley
which according to this theory Odin
originally commissioned them to forge an
Infinity Gauntlet for him but then his
infinity stone journey led him to
vermeer where the soul stone required
Odin to sacrifice someone he loved and
Thanos's case of course it was his
daughter Gamora so perhaps for Odin it
would be his daughter hella presumably
Odin was unable to go through with it
because you know he'll is still alive
this could have led helots who consider
her father weak and turn against him and
she would go after the stones herself
but then failing in her mutiny Odin
banished her to hell and gave up his
quest for the Infinity stones he then
hid the space stone on Midgard
aka earth in that temple in Norway that
we saw in the beginning of Captain
America the First Avenger and then he
handed it Billy or make a replica
gauntlet for his vault as a reminder
his exploits and the pain of what he
went through with hella beautiful ear
could have then used this mold to make a
new gauntlet when Thanos arrived this
idea of a replica could explain the
vault seen in Ragnarok which a lot of
you were asking about bank this stuff is
fake weak smaller than I thought OPP
that's not bad now for some viewers
Hellas fake line was a little confusing
right because if as we learn infinity
war the gauntlet was forged for Thanos
only recently how would Helen know of
another gauntlet to compare this fake
one to but this theory answers that
question hella would be well aware of
what the Infinity Gauntlet is and what a
fake one would look like and this
explains why she would be impressed by
the tesseract which she knows as a space
stone it would also explain why hella is
so insulted to see Odin's fake treasure
like the murals above that hella had
just torn down these represent a revised
history that her father told himself to
hide from his dark past one that erases
her from the historical record and if
this theory is true it also presents a
possible look at fan OSes future the
final shot of him an infinity war with
him peacefully sitting and watching the
sunrise it reminded me a lot of Odin's
death scene and thor ragnarok calmly
sitting on the norwegian cliff side both
Odin and Thanos are conquerors of the
cosmos they've used the space stone to
jump from planet to planet and kill a
lot of people and in these moments of
reflection for them the number one thing
that would probably be haunting them in
this moment is their daughters perhaps
one way Avengers 4 could go is to seethe
anos reflect upon his conquest in a
similar way what's it all worth it could
I have been a better father I don't know
one way to bring him down could be for
the Avengers to tap into that sense of
regret that old war mongers have after
the dust is settled
and speaking of dust it is worth
pointing out that Odin's death featured
him fading into dust not too differently
from the way they enosis victims did I'm
just saying there's clearly a parallel
between these characters and I predict
that the final battle with Thanos will
continue to map Thor nebula and the rest
of the Avengers relationship with the
mad Titan over the past relationship
with the all-father this is all about
daddy issues how do a group of angry
kids get back at their dad for grounding
them and killing half of them
abcess Thor has done with Odin they have
to prove to daddy that they're worthy
Orido steal daddy's gauntlet kill him
but a question for you guys do you see
theo says more similar of a character to
odin or to Ultron
remember Ultron also wanted to save
humanity through genocide actually there
is a theory out there that Ultron could
still be alive but stay tuned for that
enough future video comment down below
with your thoughts or tweet me directly
at us and follow new rock stars on
Twitter for updates on our videos like
this video share it around subscribe to
new rock stars for all of our infinity
war deep dives and theories and remember
kids if you see an Infinity Gauntlet
lying around hell is right it's probably
fake oh my god
[Music]